you know how sometimes we conservatives
get a little blunt with our rhetoric and
we just come right out and say that the
Liberals and the Democrats promote evil
and then the Liberals and the Democrats
deny it and then the squish Republicans
say that we're being hyperbolic and
engaging in irresponsible inflammatory
rhetoric and that our opponents don't
promote evil they just have a difference
of opinion and blah blah blah so
yesterday Democrat Senator Juan Mendes
extolled the virtue of Satanism in the
Arizona State Capital members uh I would
like to introduce a group of arizonans
uh some from my district but they have
membership all across the state they are
here today to confront the arbitrary
tyrannical authority of religious
persecution that's scheduled for
government committee later on today uh
today members uh I want to introduce you
to memb we we are graced with the
presence of ministers and members of the
satanic temple of Arizona please stand
today uh they're at the capital today to
fight for the rights of their more than
12,000 members of their denomination and
the rights of free speech and free
exercise of all arizonans uh the temple
practices non-theistic Satanism divorced
from Superstition without any belief in
gods or Devils they practice the
religious uh they they practice the the
religious values of compassion Justice
bodily autonomy Free Speech science
humility and Noble action as an
organized religion they they actively do
Outreach and community service and
participate in public affairs where
their issues might benefit where the
issues might benefit from their rational
satanic insights the mission of the
satanic temple is to encourage Bel
belovedness and empathy among all people
of course he's wearing a mask the public
according to Senator Mendes might
benefit from their rational satanic
insights and quote their courage and
their benevolence whatever that is I
think he was trying to say benevolence
which means means good will which is a
strange trait to attribute to the father
of Lies who fell like lightning from
Heaven to devour us all and torture us
forever in an eternal pit of despair now
I obviously have a different view from
Senator Mendes and the rest of the
Liberals it seems to me that you
actually don't have to hand it to Satan
ever under any circumstances seems to me
that if your ideology leads you to
worshiping the devil then you've
probably taken a wrong turn somewhere in
your logic but I know what Senator
Mendes would say he would say what the
satanists say he was reading from their
press release which says that they don't
actually worship Satan it's all just
ironic they really just worship Humanity
they worship the self because they don't
believe in anything higher than the self
I know that's what they say what they
don't realize is is John Milton said
that too in Paradise Lost they don't
realize that the serpent said that too
in the Garden of Eden when he tempted
Eve by promising ye shall be his Gods
what these supposedly ironic satanists
are doing to the Applause of liberal
politicians is precisely what Satanism
has always been about liberalism and
Satanism ultimately come down to the
same thing idolatry of the self when
conservatives have pointed that out
we've been called hyperbolist and Cooks
now the Liberals are admitting it
themselves and when people show you
explicitly and emphatically who they are
it is usually prudent to believe them
I'm Michael nolles this is the Michael
nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show Disney
reportedly wants to replace Johnny Depp
with a black woman of course in Pirates
of the Caribbean uh we'll get to that in
a moment first though on the topic of
left-wing politicians and black people
and white people I guess uh Julius
malma in South Africa is poised to take
a lot of seats in the South African
Parliament he is the leader of what was
once the third largest party in the
South African Parliament but now it
looks like it's making some pretty big
gains for those of you who are not
familiar with Julius malma he is most
famous for calling for the genocide of
white people in South Africa must never
be scared to
kill a revolution demands that at some
point there must be killing because the
killing is part of a revolutionary
act I I I don't know what's going to
happen in the future I'm saying to you
we have not called for the killing of
white people at least for now I can't
guarantee the future yeah but I mean
you'd understand somebody watching that
especially as it gets shared on Twitter
they freak out it sounds like a
genocidal cry babies cry babies I'm not
calling for the slaughter of white
people at least for
now I can't give guarantee of the future
especially when things are going the way
they are subtext especially things if
things are going the way they are there
will be a revolution in this country I
can tell you
now and then we will kill all the white
people it's not even subtext it's just
it's just text he saying never be afraid
of killing the white people there's a
famous chant that malma leads which is
kill the B shoot to kill kill the
farmer so that's what they want to do
they want to they want to kill the white
people and uh right now thec the leading
party there is losing its majority
according to a recent poll and you're
seeing major gains for the eff which is
the party that that guy
leads you're not allowed to say that
because because we're told even the very
term white genocide the thing that that
guy is explicitly calling for that's a
crazy conspiracy theory and you're not
allowed to talk about it right if you
use that phrase on social media if you
mention it in the news you're called a
crazy conspiracy theorist even though
it's the sort of thing that that guy is
directly calling for maybe not yet but
he also is calling for it yet right he's
also saying don't be afraid to kill
these
people which shows you that not
only according to our modern culture can
you not be racist against white people
apparently you can't even commit
genocide against them even if you kill
them all there 4 million white people in
South Africa and there have been
increasing attacks on them in recent
years and raids on white farmers and
murders of white farmers in their
families and you're not allowed to
mention it you're suspected of being a
kind of a racist if you ever even
mention that you can't what do you can't
the the reason you can't be racist
against white people is because racism
is the sort of thing white people do
that's how they Define it racism is a a
relatively new term and the way that the
libs get to control it is they just
Define it as saying well it's the sort
of thing that white people can't be or
the sort of thing that you can't be
against white people rather the sort of
thing that only white people can be same
thing with genocide genocide is a
relatively new term the term genocide
only cropped up after the second world
war and it was used to refer
specifically to Hitler's attacks on the
Jews so that was the original context
it's been broadened out
somewhat but it Remains the case
according to our leading genius experts
that you you can't commit a genocide
against white people it's not possible
and and the
abstract really academic intellectual
reasons for this are the same sort of
thing we hear all the time white people
have no culture white people are not a
real race white people are a historical
novelty white people have all the Power
white people this white people that
white people this but the end result is
the same it's not merely that white
people will be discriminated against by
law in certain countries including in
our own country by the way as long as
affirmative action was on the books it's
it's not merely that white people will
be discriminated against by the culture
and encouraged to be discriminated
against by the culture as is the case in
many countries including our own it's
that a major country South Africa is not
just some far-flung
uh you know Backwater South Africa is a
major country can call for the genocide
of white people and you won't really be
able to say boo about it you you
certainly won't get an
audience now speaking of killing
speaking of major threats uh we have to
protect innocent people including the
most innocent people that's why you got
to check out pre-born right now go to
preborn docomo every day pre-born
Network clinics rescue 200 unborn babies
by introducing a mother to her child via
ultrasound a baby's chance of survival
could double I met someone and I got
pregnant and I wasn't ready when I was
at the clinic after they told me how far
long I was and that the baby had a
heartbeat I cried and it gave me a
minute by myself in the room I broke
down and I prayed to God I asked the
Lord to when I walk out of those doors
to just give me the strength to be able
to go through the pregnancy made my
decision at that time treasure I chose
because I know that she was a gift from
God and she's just going to be a
treasure I'm super grateful that I'm
able to go down this journey with my
daughter and I'm just super glad that I
didn't have
abortion one ultrasound is just 28 bucks
140 bucks will offer five babies a
chance at life just out pound 250 say
keyword baby Pound 250 keyword baby or
donate securely at preborn docomo
preborn
docomond speaking of interracial
dialogue my favorite clip that has gone
around since ice ice spice's new song
when so I guess it's only been in the
last 24 hours my favorite clip in any
case that has been going around the
internet is care of a woman named Suki
and another woman named Bobby altof who
is a young podcaster I take it and they
were uh really almost coming to blows
over the host's suggestion that the
musician is a good musician what do you
know that you're a
musician but that's why I'm interviewing
you today so I can get to know you so
I'm a musician M what the that mean make
magic or something what is musician I
think that's I I think you're confusing
not yeah I'm not no musician I make
music I make music and that's not all I
do I make music I act I'm a TV star too
a young M I just really quick I think
you're confusing I'm not confusing
nothing because you you don't know you
thought that all I was was a magician or
whatever the f you say see that's what I
think you think I said I said musician
not magician I don't think baby I don't
think what is that that's ghetto I don't
think I know so you you think I didn't
say magician Su I said
musician and I think you are a musician
no baby I do music so you just really
just really quick for the record could
you say you don't think you're a
musician I'm not none of that but then
after that you just said I do music yeah
I do music so in other words you're a
musician no I'm not
okay who's on first who's on second no
who's On First I don't know Third Base
that's what this is this is obviously a
bit some people were sharing this as
though this were a sincere or
miscommunication it's obviously a bit
and it's a very funny
bit it's a it's a version in a way of
like an old Abbott and Costello routine
but it's also and and this is more to
the cultural Point here the specific
kind of bit this is is a minstral act
and we live at a time where we're
erasing all sorts of characters and all
sorts of uh shows and forms of Art and
jokes because they're supposedly racist
and they're supposedly racist because
they come from minstral we got rid of
Anima from the pancake syrup bottle
because it was supposedly uh so racist
deriving from the minstral tradition and
and it does the anima character does
come from the minstral tradition uh the
irony of it is that the anima character
was created by a black writer named
Billy cand who is one of the most famous
minstral performers in history but we're
not allowed to do that now anytime a
woman puts a little too much uh
concealer on for Halloween we're all
trying to figure out if if she put on
blackface and to see if we can cancel
her because you got to get rid of menaly
but this is a minstral act and
everyone's laughing at it right now
because they refuse to acknowledge that
just like the Tracy Morgan character in
30 Rock was a it was a funny bit but it
was a minstral bit the whole the joke of
it was he's a caricature of black
culture and he seems kind of dumb and
you know he he seems uh silly and
frivolous and it's kind of funny it's
funny you know to make fun of any kind
of a culture but we're told
intellectually today you're not in any
way allowed to make fun of black people
except we all we do it it's not us I
didn't it a bunch of Libs made dirty
Rock I am quite certain that Suki and
this host Bobby alov are not right-wing
conservatives they're probably not Trump
supporters right even the the sitcoms of
the 1970s great shows The Jeffersons
Good Times all those Norman Lear shows
they were they were kind of minstral
shows so all of this to say it's not
that I'm defending minstral or whatever
I'm not defending sukiana or any of
these people uh my point is more a
historical point we look back and we
throw stones at all of our forebears and
all how racist our grandparents were and
how evil and rotten and terrible
everyone was whoever came before
us we are doing the exact same
things and in many cases what we are
doing today is much worse take the
theatrical tradition and comedy bits
aside for a second we we like to look
back on history and say can you believe
that
for two or 3 hundred years in America we
tolerated a particularly egregious form
of slavery yeah man that's terrible you
know we kill 800,000 babies a year now
you know that right no no no that's good
Michael that's autonomy that's Freedom
that yeah I'm just saying in the future
maybe people will look kind of negative
on that seems a little crazy to me
everyone's going to be laughing at this
bit everyone but when we look back in
history people do the same kind of
things these same themes that recur
throughout history it's bad when they do
it it's fine when we do it it's very bad
when they do it speaking of putting on
an
act nearly half
[Music]
of uh speaking
of
there's a Missouri Secretary of State
candidate who is
uh she's got maybe the greatest campaign
ad of the year uh her campaign ad
consists in lighting LGBT books that are
put in front of little kids on
fire these are what I will do to the
groom books when I become Secretary of
State Main
these booksi Public Library when I'm in
office they will
[Music]
burn now hold on hold on a second I have
a question about this ad and my question
is what is the maximum donation Allowed
by law that one can make to a Missouri
Secretary of State
candidate that that's my only question
actually what an ad what an ad valid
Tina Gomez a woman on a
mission when I'm in office these books
will burn and now I know book bans and
book burning they get a a bad rap these
days but uh virtually every serious
thinker for all of history has has
supported some degree of book Banning or
censorship and many of them supported
book burning going back to I don't know
like Plato the apostle Souls um the the
great Geniuses of the Middle Ages the
Scholastics even people who are not not
exactly on my side of viewing things you
know I think like Martin Luther you know
not my main man but that guy burned
books that you know you get this recurs
throughout history okay and we have
plenty of book bands today what's funny
is that the libs pretend they always
have these lists of the most banned
books and it's always like to Kill a
Mocking Bird or something one of the
bestselling novels ever that every
School child reads by the time he's 12
that's not a Banned
Book there there are legitimately banned
books go like a some like Holocaust
denying historian that's a ban go try to
buy one of those books you're not going
to find that anywhere and I'm not I'm
not arguing that certain books shouldn't
be banned it's the libs who are saying
that certain books shouldn't be banned
but they're the ones who ban all the
books forget about books that that most
people would object to even just get
down to the the one book you're not
allowed to teach in schools the Bible
That's the book The Libs support that
book ban they would probably burn it if
they had the
chance but they're going to get on this
woman they'll say she's a threat she's
an authoritarian she wants to censor
that
woman compared to the liberal
establishment that woman is as
open-minded as they come now when you
want to put out fires one great way to
do it is with woke tears which is why
you got to check out woke Teater right
now go to woke tat.com seems like
wokeism is everywhere it's in the air we
breathe the news we watch even in the
water we drink that is
why woke tears bottled water an American
brand is on a mission to save America
from the brave new woke world one sip at
a time woke teers water is a legitimate
brand of drinking water bottled right
here in the US by people who know what a
woman is made from Pure snowflake
meltdowns woke te's water is making
hydration great again while everyone
else's water is just water woke tius
provides a refreshing gulp of laughter
in a world thirsty for sanity if you
want to try woke tiwater visit woke
tat.com indulge today in laughter and
hydration two of the most important
things in your life right now go to woke
tears
water.com today I love that this has
clearly taken some inspiration from our
famous Tumblr great great thing to be
sipping around the office woke tears
water.com the daily wi is looking to add
an experienced senior social media
manager to our marketing team this
unique Position will provide leadership
and guidance on various daily wire
social media Pages if you have over four
years of experience managing social
media teams apply now don't miss out on
this extraordinary opportunity to do
brilliant work that matters join us in
shaping the future of conservative media
as our senior social media manager if
you're interested in joining our team
visit dailywire.com careers that is
dailywire.com careers today
speaking of political
donations R McDaniel is reportedly out
as the chairman of the Republican
National Committee according to reports
R McDaniel has told president Trump that
she plans to step down shortly after the
South Carolina primary in February 24th
you'll remember there was a pretty
bruising battle for the chairmanship of
the RNC everyone was convinced that
harit Dylan the Challenger was going to
win this race I like meet very much have
a lot of respect for her I didn't think
that was going to happen I knew R was
going to get reelected and she did but
it looks as though now she might not
even finish out her term uh looks like
she's Fallen a foul of President Trump
or he just thinks that they need someone
new so reportedly Trump wants to promote
the chairman of the North Carolina
Republican party Michael Watley as her
replacement and there you know Trump
doesn't get to just pick the RNC
chairman even though Trump is
effectively the leader of the Republican
party right now so there will be some
kind of election but probably what Trump
wants will go a lot of people really
they hate R McDaniel they they blame her
for Republican
losses a lot of people think this is a
major embarrassment for Ron McDaniel
that she's being pushed out I my take on
it is sort of just
whatever whatever I have an unpopular
opinion here I guess which is I don't
think the RNC actually matters all that
much I don't really think the DNC
matters all that much I don't think the
party committees I'm not saying they
have no influence but compared to
candidates who are who are the the real
face of the party and who actually
determine elections much more than party
chairman compared to the candidates
compared to the political action
committees compared to the super packs I
just don't think the RNC carries all
that much weight also Ron McDaniel's
been in that office now for what six
seven years that is two to almost four
times longer than most people a lot of a
lot of RNC chairman historically serve
for a couple years some serve for only
one year some for a couple years maybe
you get to like four years but but Ron
McDaniel's been in it for a long time
and some of the elections have been
disappointing no doubt about it but I I
don't know I just don't blame the the
party flax I kind of think it's a matter
of well in certain cases it might be a
matter of rigging the election system
and using CO as the excuse but in other
cases it's the candidates and in other
cases it's the the packs and the super
packs which actually fund the campaigns
and in other cases it's just the
political
mood so ra okay she's out I just I'm not
saying she should stay in the office but
just I don't think it's quite such the
big news that the Beltway Elites want to
pretend that it is now certain
leadership in the party really does
matter especially when we're talking
about leadership in the US Senate the
Senate Majority Leader wields insane
amount of power not just in the Senate
but also from the leadership packs that
will fund other candidates pick other
candidates around the country really
affect the outcome of
races and Senator Cruz is now calling
for the ouster of Senate Majority Leader
cocaine Mitch everyone here also
supported a leadership challenge to
Mitch McConnell in
November uh I think a Republican leader
should actually lead this conference and
should Advance the priorities of
Republicans and I stood up and said look
in any ordinary organization when you
are faced with failure if you're running
a business and you lose $50 million you
don't just say hey everything's great
let's keep doing it no you sit down and
say what are we doing
wrong and at that meeting I turned to
Mitch McConnell then and I said look we
spent the last two years with a group a
handful of Republicans joining with
Democrats to pass the Democrat
agenda I said may maybe that's a good
idea I I don't think it is but someone
could make the argument that's a good
idea I love the way he says that no look
maybe there's someone out there I
wouldn't make that argument because I'm
intelligent and I have a vision for the
party and Senator Cruz is obviously
right as he is right about most things
by far the best Republican senator and
uh one of the best Republicans that
we've had in the country in my entire
lifetime um I'm not a total Mitch hater
you know that I'm grateful to Senator
McConnell for standing firm on the
judges he he really held firm when
Justice Scalia died during the 2016
election he held firm he did not allow
Barack Obama to replace Scalia which
meant that we got a conservative judge
in his place and then we got more
conservative judges and then we
overruled roie Wade so I'm far from a
cocaine Mitch hater but what this is
about is this immigration bill that
Mitch McConnell really tried to push
which would have been a complete
concession On the Border would have
opened the Border even more it's
completely unnecessary you don't need a
legislative fix to the border crisis the
Border crisis is a result of the Biden
Administration refusing to enforce
current federal law so it's just a
complete a complete Miss and it's
probably time for cocaine Mitch to go I
think Senator Cruz is probably right
here probably need some new leadership
and part of the reason that the
conservatives have been angry at Mitch
McConnell for many years now part of the
reason I think this leadership challenge
could get a little bit more oomph right
now is one because it Mitch recently
betrayed the conservatives on a major
issue like the defining issue of the
last 10 years which is mass migration
the defining issue for conservatives not
only in America but in Britain in Italy
in Hungary in France in Germany in like
all over the west and McConnell totally
toned if and he hung Senator Jim
Langford out to dry on it he made him
the face of it but it was a deal
obviously negotiated by McConnell and
Schumer and the other reason why the
leader leadership challenge would get
some oomph right now is because Matt
Gates has largely been Vindicated on
outing Kevin McCarthy I wasn't a total
McCarthy hater either I felt Kevin
McCarthy was probably the most
conservative Speaker of the House of my
lifetime and yet it's damning with faint
praise the conservatives in the house
felt that he had betrayed them they
pushed him out they get this guy Mike
Johnson instead and Mike Johnson kills
the stupid immigration Bill great looks
like a Vindication for me not only can
the replacement of an establishment guy
in leadership with a conser ative can it
be good but we've got evidence that it
has turned out to be pretty good if I
were cocaine Mitch I would seriously be
considering stepping down now the guy
that Mitch McConnell hung out to dry on
this immigration Bill Jim Langford from
Oklahoma I have a a fair amount of pity
for him he's trying to push this bill
that nobody want well Democrats and
squishes want it but the conservatives
don't want it he's getting absolutely
eviscerated over it I I've always kind
of liked Jim Langford I don't have
anything against him but this was a huge
huge miscalculation and now Senator
Langford is playing victim some of may
have policy differences some of them
have been very clear with me they have
political differences with the bill they
say it's the wrong time to solve the
problem or let the presidential election
solve this
problem in fact I had
a popular
commentator four weeks ago that I talked
to that told me flat out before they
knew any of the contents of the bill any
of the content none nothing was out at
that point that told me flat out if you
try to move a bill that solves the
Border crisis during this presidential
year I will do whatever I can to destroy
you because I do not want you to solve
this during the presidential election by
the way they have been faithful to their
promise and have done everything they
can to destroy me in the past several
weeks I don't know who the commentator
is it wasn't me actually but the
commentator was right but the
commentator was was even more right than
he lets on in the telling of Senator
Langford here the issue is not simply
that we don't want to solve this problem
in an election year we want to let the
presidential election solve it that's a
that's a great way for the squishes in
the establishment to frame the issue the
issue is
we don't stand to benefit at all from
this bill there's no benef forget the
political benefits or harms during an
election
year we know for a fact the Democrats
are not negotiating in good faith we
know for a fact they're not ex they're
not enforcing the current law and
they're saying hey since we're not
enforcing the current law we're going to
force you to the table to pass a new law
that that maybe we'll enforce but
there's no reason to believe they would
enforce the new one
either and and the new law they want to
pass would not reduce illegal
immigration it would increase it almost
certainly and it would not reduce
migration broadly which is what most
Americans want it would dramatically
increase migration and it would give
Democrats new voters and it's just a
complete disaster and so as I said
before I generally like Jim Langford and
I feel bad for him here I'm feeling less
bad for him and I'm liking him less the
more he whes and cries and plays the
victim here no this isn't about those
those self-interested conservatives
trying to win an election this is about
your failure your horrible political
miscalculation to believe Mitch
McConnell and the
Democrats and and to push a bill that
would increase migration which we don't
want we have too many people coming into
the country call me crazy I think four
million foreigners a year coming into
the country is a little much in a
country of 330 million people and I
think that when you have the largest
movement of people ever in recorded
history over the last 60 years into this
country it's a little much maybe we can
put put the push the braks a little
bit I I'm I'm losing a lot of my
sympathy for Jim Langford here just
admit you screwed up this is a stupid
Bill and kill it and try to do better
next time wow I don't know why are
people being so mean because you're
pushing a horrible bill that none of us
want that would give Democrats probably
a permanent electoral majority and
everyone makes mistakes and we're
willing to forgive you but stop whining
and man up and kill the bill good grief
speaking of Republicans failing in
Congress Alejandro
mayaras the secretary of the Department
of Homeland
Security was about to be impeached by
the Republicans until he wasn't the the
vote failed final vote 214 to impeach
216 don't impeach uh this was after the
House GOP Vice chairman Blake Moore from
Utah flipped to a don't impeach vote
though we shouldn't really blame him for
that the only reason he did that was to
break a tie and then hope that they can
bring this back up when uh another
Republican is back Steve scalise who was
out for Medical Treatments had Steve
Steve scales been there probably the
impeachment would have just barely
passed although I don't know maybe some
squish would have flipped in that case
too and and then they would have they
maybe we would have just once again
gotten pretty close and then it doesn't
work my question here is
not why didn't they schedule the vote
for when Steve scales was in town so
that we would have had the votes that we
need it it that's not even my issue my
issue isn't well why don't they bring it
up again next week I don't know maybe
they will bring it up again next week my
my question is this goes back a little
further Why did Republicans kick out
George Santos remember George Santos
he's the kind of wacky
crazy republican from Long Island who
apparently lied about everything in his
past and was a financial fraudster and
was a drag queen I guess and did all
he's like a weird guy you know and maybe
lied about even being a homosexual I
he's he's an odd duck I'm not telling
you he's not why' we kick him
out we kicked him out because of how
principled we are and we're so
principled that now we only have a three
vote majority in the Congress and we
can't even impeach the worst Homeland
Security secretary in history who's
flagrantly violating the law because of
how principled we are and what's the
principle exactly George Santos lied
about his ethnic Heritage oh wow we've
never seen that in the US Congress right
we don't we don't have a woman whose
nickname is Senator liia waa fah hontas
up there in the sen no well uh George
Santos was financially quite dodgy and
fraudulent oh really okay are we going
to kick out half of Congress then well
uh Santos was uh sexually deviant uhhuh
okay you going to kick out the other
half of Congress then well uh
Senator Congressman Santos was this that
or the other thing I'm not defending him
I wouldn't I wouldn't really like to
vote for the guy I don't I don't like
him at all
but why would you kick him out you dummy
Republicans oh you
just you clutch defeat from the jaws of
Victory so often to impress liberals who
hate you and who would never extend to
you any such Grace for nothing for no
end not for the end of Justice not for
the end of morality certainly not for
the end of political
flourishing
pathetic my favorite comment yesterday
is from Frank
s111 who says Joe Biden talking to
franois Mand was just him talking to one
of his millions of Voters that's a a
good point actually you're right uh
franois Mand was not able to vote for
Democrats when he was the living
president of France but now that he's
dead uh you're right actually I think
he's registered in
Pennsylvania now speaking of replacing
people Disney they've heard you you know
Disney they got a little blowback when
they were caught on camera saying that
they were pushing not so secret gay
agenda on your children Disney got a
little bit of push back when they
replaced Snow White with this woman in a
a new Snow White
story who she she emphatically you know
isn't Snow White we I call her sometimes
like um sand beige or something like
that but that that's not that's by by
far the least silly part of her Casting
the silliest part of her Casting is she
hates the story and she says we don't
want love we don't want a prince
charming we don't want this we don't
want it's obviously so woke it was
obviously Dei it was obviously you know
any kind of
traditional traditional is bad white is
bad men are bad though in that case it's
a it's a female character being replaced
by a female but now we've got a better
opportunity for Disney they've heard you
so they're going to replace Johnny Depp
with a black lady according to reports
uh the lady is IO Ed
deiri um I don't I'm not familiar with
her work she might be a fine actress but
one thing I can tell you is she's not
the Johnny Depp character because she's
not a
dude and and this would be for Pirates
of the Caribbean
six uh her character is named
an so it's not an exact onetoone of
Captain Jack Sparrow uh it's this new
character named Anne and it might be
based off a real life pirate named Anne
Bonnie who was Irish so what Disney's
pushing back and they're saying look we
want to replace all the white guys with
black ladies in the name of Dei even if
it doesn't serve the story even if it
doesn't make sense but you you racists
and you sexists you don't even
understand this is based on a real
character and the real character is a
woman well that's true but the woman's
Irish and I don't I don't think this is
what Black Irish means have you ever
heard that phrase Black Irish Black
Irish is a term used among Irish
Americans to explain why certain Irish
people here have slightly darker
features or dark hair or dark eyes but
it's totally made up this the the myth
around Black Irish is that some
Spaniards landed in Ireland some
centuries ago and that's why some of
them look a little bit more
Mediterranean uh but it it doesn't
appear to be backed up by any genetic
analysis so it's just it's just a fake
American kind of story and in any case
uh Black Irish doesn't mean actual like
African people now you might say well
Michael who cares any any person of any
race or some would say of of any sex
should be able to play any
character uh I don't think that's true
I'm some characters I think the race
doesn't really matter all characters the
sex usually matters but some the race
doesn't really matter but that view was
not the view of August Wilson the leader
of the modern American black theater
that wasn't the view of of a whole lot
of people in the history of
theater and it isn't the view of
audiences like
some
Sexes are different cultures are
different
and every time that Disney does this the
movies are
flops but they don't really care they
feel that they have hegemony so they're
going to they're going to serve it up
and doesn't matter go see it don't go
see it the Dei leftist agenda continues
a pace now speaking of women potentially
replacing men the Nevada presidential
primary took place most people didn't
pay attention to it because the
Republican primary is effectively over
and Trump is the nominee but what was
weird about Nevada is that Nevada had
both a primary and a
caucus so in Nevada it used to be that
the nomination fight was settled in a
caucus and then in 2021 the legislature
said no we're going to become a primary
State not a caucus state but the GOP
didn't like this so the GOP has held
firm to the caucus they had a separate
caucus and they said that if you
participate in the primary you don't get
to participate in the caucus
so even before all the other candidates
dropped out all most of them were going
to participate in the caucus Nikki Haley
was not Nikki Haley said no I'm going to
be in the
primary and so as a result Trump who is
the last remaining serious candidate in
the primary he was not in the Nevada
Republican presidential primary he won
the Nevada caucus which is actually
what's going to count toward the
nomination and Nikki Haley won the
Primary well no she didn't she beat Mike
Pence who was still on the ballot even
though he dropped out she beat Tim Scott
who was still on the ballot even though
he dropped out she beat John Castro who
I've never heard of even though he was
still on the ballot but she
lost to none of these
candidates Nikki got about
33% and none of these candidates got
60.4% none of these candidates got
almost twice as many votes as Nikki
Haley not a good sign now Nikki did not
really campaign in Nevada obviously she
wasn't even taking the primary seriously
that's why she wasn't in the
caucus but it's it's embarrassing it's
not it's not a good headline cycle now
they're headed to South Carolina and the
problem with South Carolina is Trump is
currently leading Nikki by at least 20
points depends which poll you look at
but maybe 30 points maybe more that's
her home state so as I've predicted for
a while Nikki is going to stay in this
race and she she said it she said' I'm
not going anywhere keep donating uh
she's going to stay in this race to be
the number two candidate to be the clear
number two once Trump gets a nomination
and then in 2028 she'll be able to claim
look I was I was the last choice if
Trump loses she can claim head you're
going with me maybe you would have won
and if even if Trump wins he's going to
be term limited out so she can she can
say look I was the number two Choice
then and she can make a credible run in
2028 and she can claim to represent the
lane that she's picked which is the more
establishment more Centrist kind of Lane
in the GOP which still represents a lot
of Voters and you can say I've got
appeal to Independence and I've got
appeal to Suburban moms and all all this
kind of stuff but one thing that is
certain is that she will not be the
Republican nominee in
2024 now another reason that Nikki Haley
is running here is because one she's a
talented politician and she's managed to
beat out all the other candidates in the
field other than Trump and two because
Biden seems so beatable I think it was
Peter Ducey who just asked White House
Press Secretary Karine janpierre if she
could maybe explain uh why Joe Biden
thought that he had just met with the
former president of France who died in
1996 here is K JP's answer how is
President Biden ever going to convince
the three4 of Voters who are worried
about his physical and mental health
that he is okay even though in Las Vegas
he told a story about recently talking
to a French president who died in
1996 I'm not even going to go down that
rabbit hole with you sir Rabbit Hole he
said he talk to Minon you saw the
president in Vegas in California you've
seen the president in South Carolina you
saw him in M Michigan I'll just leave it
there what listen I'm not even go I'm
not even gon to answer your question
which is the best answer she could give
there's no way to explain the the the
honest answer is because Joe Biden's
obviously in Decline and he's doing that
thing that your grandparents all did
just before they died which is they
confused people and they confused not
not just weeks and years but they
confused whole decades and epochs and
they forgot who's alive and who's dead
that's the honest answer so she can't
say that she goes I'm not even gonna
answer that question then he goes what
are you what are you talking about your
job is to answer the questions give it
and her the best she can muster is look
you've seen the president California
Alaska Brazil China I had eggs for
breakfast this morning look at my hand
is that a butterfly gble gobleg okay
next question that's the best thing she
just she's just going to say words so
that maybe if you put the TV on mute it
looks like she's answering the question
but her her firm answer is yeah man we
got nothing we got we've got
nothing as it pertains to a rational
debate over Joe Biden's uh case for
reelection we got nothing there the best
they're going to hope for is that they
can keep rigging the the elections with
uh losing voter ID with promoting
widespread mail and ballots and with
encouraging ballot harvesting that's
their only chance and maybe they think
it's a good chance and they don't think
they have to answer to the people okay
it's theology Thursday baby and
Professor
Jacob I don't know why I keep giving him
more and more rights and freedoms on
this show he has insisted that we play a
new game it's going to be a Bible verse
game no I don't know listen Professor
Jacob he was schooled by those hodnik
over there so I don't know list I was
not you know I was I was school I had
semi- we catechesis and then so I don't
know maybe he's going to get me we'll
find out you can help me the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code NES
canw check out for 2 months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans